[Musique]
je serai 6 4
je jetterai mutation et je l'en
prescrirait des antilles les plus sûres
[Musique]
je parle d'un temps que les moins de
vingt ans ne peuvent pas connaître
la boîte bas je suis tout le monde sur
quelles chansons qui m'ont 10 pouces 1/4
voilà non c'est vrai tu t on pas là par
météo pas la travailler plus comme ça je
concentre l'année prochaine quand il
sera sur nt1 j'adore l'asie mais je
pense que je pense que je suis très
attaché aussi avec habitudes françaises
prendre un café en terrasse et bien
original comme une bonne parisienne
parce que ça n'existe pas en chine des
branchies tout sur eux
[Musique]
je me suiciderai dames anse à veau
celle-ci chicago comme un coupé court
[Musique]
j'aimerais tourner avec louis garrel
si on faisait chaud aussi
[Musique]